now do you just hang out for the show or
are you actually friends no we are
actually friends will be very good
friends Robbie's one of my one of my
best mates what I would say is that when
because Rob and I started out doing
stand up together and we you know the
early gigs we saw each other and and
what I would say about Rob is when I
first saw him I would describe his
energy as highly punchable and so the
idea the idea that I'd have ended up
being friends with him didn't really
occur to me but as I got to know him you
sort of you sort of get beyond that and
we'd become very good friends of mine
I'm basically a vitamin supplement for
rubbish he doesn't wanted to have me but
he needs me
yeah I mean so like and you forget to
take a bottom bit so I will be in his
face and so sometimes annoying me into
doing stuff I think you're happy that
we've done it after the wrong yeah but
what I would say is that Rob doesn't
realise when he's exceeded my RDA
liberty' which I've had enough of its
have been and Rob keeps on dosing up is
you can dive too much bitumen say you
can't I started turning orange getting
really annoyed
[Music]
you